i also believe that old adage whether  you think you can or you think you can't  you're right you know and you know i  think there's been a lot of  uh  hype or or there's been kind of this  sway in in our  culture that  leads to  people feeling  that they are a victim and i don't  really fall for that um yeah okay i'm a  white male  you know and so you go okay you don't  have it well i didn't grow up with a  silver spoon you know again i had a  wooden spoon upside my head maybe but  that's about it  and so  i don't think that  and yes it is harder for minority and  yes it is harder for a lot of different  groups but  if you decide you want to make something  i think in this country there is a  pathway to do that